ciao ciao a tutti l'educazione è un gran
casino credo nel senso che tirar fuori
il fuoco dentro di noi in grande il
grande tema della vita no e come fare ad
arrivarci insomma credo che sia proprio
un grande casino io uso il gela scusa
del design per fare un sacco di roba e
il design per me e soprattutto insomma
cercare di avvicinare il fuoco ha il
fuoco dentro e tirarlo fuori
ok quindi per me l'educazione una cosa
che intanto non è delegata solamente al
periodo di un liceo di una formazione
specifica ma in tutta la vita
io ogni giorno mi sveglio cercando di
essere un pelino meno rimbambito ok
quindi questo per me è la pensione
dovremmo avere nella vita costantemente
per fare questo è un grande casino
perché ovviamente devi devi segnarti sul
suo diario a sinistra quello che fai a
destra come ti senti
no e quindi quando inizia a capire dove
ti senti bene premente quello il
mestiere della tua vita quindi cercare
di portare le persone a fare quello che
mi piace fare la cosa più semplice del
mondo ma anche più difficile quindi
siamo vi racconterò un po della mia
esperienza e vi racconterò insomma
quello che abbiamo cercato di fare in
dieci anni poi di percorso che
riguardano il design
abbiamo rimesso le persone al centro è
però rimette del personal gente non è
per forza da di massaggi alle 5 in
fabbrica non è perciò coccolarle ed anni
quello che serve e quindi no il buon
maestro è quello che ti dà quello che
serve non è quello che ti dà quello che
vorrei stia volte all'educazione ma
sempre in quella direzione e l'empatia è
uno dei termini che noi il lago stiamo
portando avanti negli ultimi cinque anni
in maniera in maniera molto decisa ma
non tanto perché seguiamo le mode e
delle neuroscienze che sono diventate
super trendy ma tanto perché è una dei
dei drivers che non è su cui potremo
costruire
c'è un grande futuro hanno già deciso no
più o meno le tecnologie nei prossimi
dieci anni
sostituiranno o elimineranno tantissimi
lavori altro che internet ha uffici
dobbiamo tornare a tutta sta roba qua
per fare internet of things che ci
serviranno quindi l'empatia proprio la
capacità umana di sentire io adesso sono
super emozionato perché un sacco di
gente che mi sta ascoltando e sentire
questa cosa qua mi fa poi entrare
possibilmente in tour in colle con le
cose che sta dicendo
ed è molto probabile perché il design
esattamente il mio linguaggio del corpo
io sto facendo fatica a mettere in
un'organizzazione le parole che sto per
fare per uscire dalla mia bocca ok ma è
molto più probabile che il linguaggio
del mio corpo che vi dice tante cose
allora insomma l'empatia secondo me è un
tema centrale su cui costruiremo in
prospettiva veramente una grande umanità
ed è su questo che noi ci stiamo
concentrando sugli ultimi tempi tutto
questo per dire che il design per come
lo interpretiamo noi e cultura
il design per come lo vedo io è una
visione olistica di un'impresa alla
visione olistica di una scuola visione
olistica di uno stato e interpretiamo
questa disciplina che ha straordinaria
perché ti dà la possibilità di sporcarti
lima di sporcarsi le mani di progettare
un attimo un tavolo ma anche di
preoccuparti di quello che succede
intorno al tavolo
allora abbiamo cerchiamo perché non
siamo in continuo divenire
abbiamo fatto un manifesto dove il punto
se hai un punto vuoto perché siamo in
continuo divenire non abbiamo verità
assoluta in mano mai non c'è nulla che
ormai è fermo il potere che cosa è fermo
il potere si sposta continuamente anche
anche anche la conoscenza si sposta
continuamente era per cui dobbiamo
allenarci proprio in questo divenire e
noi crediamo abbiamo questa se vogliamo
che un po utopia che gli spazi possono
anche educarci noi non mangiamo solo
cibo noi mangiamo anche quello che
vediamo noi mangiamo quello che viviamo
le nostre esperienze
sono il nostro cibo no quindi siamo
straconvinti che partire da un tavolo
perché come dire quello lì è un oggetto
che mi rappresenta tutto il mondo divide
ma anche unisce possa essere molto
rilevante e mi sono accorto che
visitando un sacco di case a volte anche
di amici bellissime ho trovato magari
tristezza dentro allora mi sono chiesto
cioè dobbiamo sì progettare il tavolo ma
dobbiamo che preoccuparci di far
succedere cose interessanti e rilevanti
un giorno e per cui da adesso mi metto
il cappellino da imprenditore non da
designer dal produttore dei tavoli dico
che è più importante quello che succede
intorno al tavolo perché alla fine noi
dobbiamo generare spazi vitali ed è il
vuoto che rende vitale il tutto non è
certo il pieno però se il pieno è
pensato in maniera intelligente
probabilmente fantucci verso la vitalità
del vuoto e quindi questa è la nostra
attenzione
abbiamo fatto una proprio velocemente
abbiamo concepito una fabbrica che era
stata progettata da un architetto che ha
fatto solo case per vi abbiamo fatto una
grande casa ok dove i tramonti entrano
dentro dove insomma abbiamo concepito un
luogo dove l'entusiasmo possa regnare
sovrano
abbiamo immaginato hyper modalità per
potare design nel mondo e per via
apriamo delle case vedere dove c'è della
gente vera che racconta il design della
lago e racconta anche tanti difetti
io trovo straordinario perché non
crediamo più a tutte queste campagne
chetino che ti rappresentano mondi
stucchevoli la vita anche un difetto e
ben venga il difetto quindi educare per
me è proprio far uscire le farfalle dal
maso cioè educare e dare questa grande
dimensione di apertura ok e di cercar di
far volare tutte le persone ed è un
lavoro difficile però insomma sono
strafelice di partecipare adesso con
questo progetto perché è una
è una cosa veramente straordinaria e che
produrrà il futuro non solo dell'italia
ma del mondo intero no qua faccio un
altro ragionamento perché a volte per
per dare esempi
no dobbiamo anche portare a noi e per
portare a noi cosa dobbiamo fare
dobbiamo sedurre ok e la seduzione un
tema centrale per cercare di dare esempi
ok una seduzione buona ovviamente allora
credo che anche i luoghi dell'imparare
possano diventare seduti e ovvio che se
poi l'hardware e seduttivo e il docente
un educatore non lo è si porrà un altro
tipo di problema però credo che se fa un
lavoro d'orchestra ok credo che riesci a
far tirar fuori un sacco di farfalle da
questi da questi ragazzi abbiamo cercato
di fare il lavoro che sappiamo fare
meglio che quello dell'abbraccio è
quello di far diventare la braccia di
casa tanti luoghi dove insomma dove
cerchiamo di metterci un po la testa e
le mani una grande accessibilità qualche
innovazione perché i banchi hanno questo
aspetto di morbidezza e quindi se hanno
un aspetto di accoglienza perché non
sono rigidi nei bordi ok hanno un
materiale che si che si deforma e
soprattutto un grande abbraccio
casalingo ecco si chiama dell'educazione
poi stiamo sviluppando un altro progetto
molto molto interessante con ne ha
contattato sei sette mesi fa a questo
questo attore che è abbastanza noto che
si chiama savino che ha una festa
incredibile e siamo diventati quasi
amici e stiamo facendo un percorso
proprio in altri aspetti ok in altri
ambiti ma comunque molto centrali
sull'educazione per che approviamo qui a
dicembre una scuola per attori a firenze
in centro e con lui probabilmente stiamo
immaginando c anche proprio una compagna
di di cosa può significare ogni giorno
imparare delle cose ok e quindi credo
che questo tema dell'educazione non è un
tema solo delegato a determinati luoghi
ma dobbiamo far diventare
tutti i giorni dobbiamo essere noi le
università tra l'altro vi parla un
grandissimo girone perché in termini di
carriera scolastica sono veramente
scarso e quindi abbiamo sviluppato
questa questa scuola per attori e adesso
stiamo installando sono foto ho
abbastanza di cantiere e andremo anche
lì a capire come l'educazione posso fare
tanto per un sacco di cose
questa è un'altra cosa che abbiamo fatto
invece a torino con lavazza è vero che
abbiamo creato una sorta di caffetteria
polivalente all'interno di una
università legata al design e qui e di
là del ripeto di concepire ambienti
abbiamo cercato di mettere network tutti
abbiamo cercato di coinvolgere tutto il
quartiere di torino ok per far sì che i
ragazzi si collegano ecc i colleghi nel
quartiere che si mangi cibi diversi che
vadano a persone diverse no a volte
abbiamo le università volte sono
naturali a padova quando iniziato il
fenomeno degli spritz era un grande
brainstorming naturale non blocchiamo lì
non blocchiamo li please
quelli sono delle robe incredibili
perché si trovano quelli che studiano
umanistica quelli che fanno le scienze e
si trovano a bere uno spritz magari
intanto si ubriacano e anche ma chi se
ne frega
quella alla scuola quella la formazione
ma allora io tifo quella roba l'impiccio
quella roba che va letta e probabilmente
va anche accompagnata da qualche maniera
insomma spinta mi fermo grazie mille